James and his mother survived the cult
from which hundreds of people have died
they were followers of Kenyan
Evangelical Pastor Paul McKenzie
they asked us to hide their identities
most other survivors are being held by
the police
this is where Mackenzie called people to
live with him in a remote Arab Forest
near Kenya's Coast
he told them to First starve their
children to death and then starve
themselves to reach heaven
James says his brother rescued him he's
visibly emaciated his mother denies she
was starving him
James says years before he was inspired
by MacKenzie's preaching in church
his messages were okay early on but they
changed from 2017 on he told us to stop
going to school and to pray instead of
going to hospital he was a senior person
so we believed him and obeyed him this
was Paul McKenzie's Church in melindi
used to stand right here every Sunday
and preach to crowds of hundreds of
people who gathered here thousands more
watched on his television station and on
YouTube his increasingly radical
preaching Drew criticism from some but
in a context where the government's
widely seemed to work only for the
benefit of a wealthy few and it's
criticized for weak provision of Public
Health Care and education his messages
of rejecting the state and modernity
resonated with many others
hundreds of them from Kenya and Beyond
followed him to the forest over the last
four years
the search for bodies and survivors has
been going on for more than a month
investigators have said there may have
been organ harvesting or bodies brought
here from other places
the police operation has since become
heavily restricted the problem was able
to exhume 15 bodies today nobody's
authorized to talk
except the regional Chief who announces
the numbers after each day of digging
thing being kind of rights groups who
were among the first to raise the alarm
say they've been excluded from the
post-mortems if you don't allow human
rights and media you allow speculations
everybody's speculating whether the
government has a hand in it or whether
the people who did this may be protected
by the government
MacKenzie's been in jail for five weeks
awaiting prosecution he was arrested
several times before but released the
government set up a commission of
inquiry to look into what happened
meanwhile people are still being found
alive some of them have refused food and
medical treatment saying they want to
continue on their Journey To Heaven
James says Mackenzie shouldn't go to
jail
I'm happy to be alive but I don't
condemn McKenzie he was a preacher with
his own beliefs I can't say anything
good or bad about him but I would advise
people to go back to the Bible and
interrogate his preachings
the town's morgue has now been filled
twice over a second round of
post-mortems is due to start on Tuesday
hundreds of people are still missing
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera malindi Kenya